los vehículos a lo largo de esta ruta
son soldados rusos que se reagrupan tras
la reciente contraofensiva Relámpago de
Ucrania aquí en el norte del dumbás la
ciudad limaman sigue bajo el control de
Rusia pero a duras penas los soldados
rusos están en guardia y es imposible
filmar su posición por motivos de
seguridad
como pueden escuchar alrededor del imán
la contraofensiva continúa el enemigo no
ha dejado de intentar atacar nuestra
defensa
limón se ha convertido en un pueblo
virtualmente fantasma las calles están
vacías y el miedo está en todas partes
la mayoría de los residentes se han ido
pero esta anciana aterrorizada permanece
siempre he vivido aquí donde debería ir
con limón ahora en la línea del frente
el sonido de los bombardeos es algo
habitual
esta mujer solo sale de su casa para
recoger comida
tenemos miedo pero necesitamos comer por
eso venimos Siempre es así
las fuerzas rusas tomaron el control del
imán a finales de mayo este hombre está
a favor de su presencia aquí ahora tema
El regreso de las tropas ucranianas
qué pasa con nosotros Quiénes somos
nadie
si los ucranianos vuelven a por acá o si
asesinatos dirán que si nos quedamos
aquí no les apoyamos
este barrio ha sido recientemente
bombardeado por las puertas ucranianas y
los residentes aquí dicen que en ningún
lugar es seguro
es peor todos los días vivimos con miedo
estamos acostumbrados a las explosiones
cuando sales a la calle golpea aquí y
luego allí y una y otra vez cuando estoy
en el jardín Boom Oh Dios mío
el presidente ucraniano bolo de
unirselenski dijo recientemente que el
actual pausa en los combates era
simplemente para preparar la siguiente
fase de ataques una declaración hecha
antes de que cuatro regiones controladas
por Rusia en Ucrania anunciaran sus
planes de celebrar referendos para
formar parte de Rusia